this is a production of cornell
university
the long island horticultural research
and extension center
is a campus of cornell university we've
been here in riverhead new york for 98
years
and our
purpose here is to help the agricultural
industry
succeed
there
is a lot of need for
up-to-date research
and assistance with growing plants
the impatiens is primarily of interest
to the greenhouse growers on long island
as well as some of the nurseries the
commercial the retail establishments
that sell plants
right here we've been breeding uh
impatience plants
trying to develop resistance to the
disease called impatience down in mildew
and um
there's always problems when you do
breeding and one of the one of the
issues that we found out with this plant
is they have what we call explosive seed
pots and it means when the seed pods are
ripe they explode and of course if
you're trying to harvest seed that's a
problem because then they're all over
the greenhouse floor
so we use we use a technique called
plant tissue culture to
assist our breeding program essentially
plant tissue culture is a way to grow
plants in a sterile environment on a
nutrient medium under controlled
environment so we will remove the pods
that we've pollinated on these plants
about 14 to 16 days after we've
pollinated them and we take those pods
to our laboratory
they're sterilized on the outside and
then they're opened aseptically to
expose the seeds and those seeds then
are placed in tissue culture to
germinate
the nice thing about that process is
that once they germinate in tissue
culture they're always going to be there
as a stock plant for us they're always
going to be available we can take
cuttings of those plants bring them out
here in the greenhouse if we find out
that we have a successful plant a
successful hybrid
we have the mother plant in tissue
culture free of diseases free of insects
and we can then rapidly propagate that
plant
to increase the numbers quickly
and these are the results of some of
that breeding research
so all these plants that you see here
are resistant to the disease we've done
field trials for them for the last two
years
but our next step then is to
produce
a plant that has a nice
uh looking flower and a nice symmetrical
growth habit so we are continuing to
hybridize these plants
and
we'll continue to
develop until we get a nice seed
propagating plants
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu